ein riesiger stuhl mitten in den
weinbergen und der heißt genauso wie das
gebiet in dem er steht
das hier sehr kaiserstuhl aber es ist
nicht der einzige denn das alles ist
auch der kaiserstuhl nicht aus holz
gezimmert sondern ein mittelgebirge
unter anderem durch vulkanausbrüche
geformt bekannt für
verdammt gutes wetter unterschiedlichste
ausflugsmöglichkeiten unglaublich viel
wein und eine ziemlich besondere
landschaft rundherum schauen wir uns
jetzt alles von unten an also runter vom
stuhl in sasbach leiselheim auf den wir
ausnahmsweise hoch dürften erste frage
was genau hat es mit diesem ding auf
sich dieses tool das war eine idee der
nabburger von leiselheim die baubehörden
haben landratsamt in emmendingen die war
nicht so sehr erbaut über dieses neue
bauwerk das hier quasi auch ohne
genehmigung errichtet worden war
ja und das dauerte hauses in schwarzbach
das dauerte dann ist endlich drei jahre
bis dann die bürger von leiselheim dann
dieses bauwerk auch tatsächlich
durchgesetzt hat sie haben den stuhl
gebaut weil einst ein späterer kaiser
hier auf einem stuhl sitzend gericht
gehalten haben soll
das hat diesem gebiet seinen namen
gegeben und es wurde dann sukzessive
übernommen auf den gesamten kaiserstuhl
den wollen wir jetzt erkunden zunächst
mit dem segway bevor es losgeht erste
fahrübungen das steuern durch
gewichtsverlagerung braucht tatsächlich
ein bisschen übung die meisten haben es
aber nach ein paar minuten drauf erzählt
andreas kiefer seit 2012 bietet er diese
segway touren an
wir fahren über die gemeinde das heißt
die meisten strecken sind so wie hier in
den reden teils verfasst aber auch viel
auf feldwegen dass er eigentlich so eine
weinwanderung aber
wir verbinden das mit einer führung das
wir zeigen den gästen bis in die
landschaft die weinberge wir erzählen
über den main und natur
es gibt jede menge themen wie kultur
natürlich die gäste fragen auch oft als
echter kaiserstühler weiß andreas die
antworten
solche segway-touren kennt man
normalerweise ja eher aus stetten
andreas hat die gefährte in die
kaiserstühler weinberge geholt
am anfang war von exoten inzwischen sind
schon sehr viele einheimische gefahren
sehr viele winzer auch mit uns
mitgefahren weil sie das einfach mal
wissen wollten wie das heißt sie sehen
ständig und am anfang wie gesagt haben
sie nur geguckt und jetzt haben es viele
auch schon ausprobiert und was einfach
schön ist dass wir sehr akzeptiert sind
das passt hier sehr gut her habe ich den
kaiserstuhl erkunden kann man
selbstverständlich auch ohne segway zum
beispiel mit dem fahrrad von wald über
rege über steil über kies überwiesen
herrliche ausblicke als einfach genial
radfahren und wandern geht natürlich
auch mit weniger steigungen zum beispiel
nach breisach eine der gemeinden am
kaiserstuhl fühlt sich fast an der
mittellinie und das ist ihr ringen einer
der vielen winzer orte hier und nach
eigener aussage wärmste ort deutschlands
wir sind das hergezogen aus freiburg vor
drei jahren und also die weite ist sehr
schön hier also ich mag das einfach weil
man sehr weit kommt mit dem fahrrad also
vermögens der gern und wetter ist
einfach schön also es hat ein paar grad
mehr als es dann doch noch in freiburg
hat ich bin hier geboren und immer mehr
hier und ich würde das gern leben hole
ich habe zwei minuten bin ich in den
bergen
immer mehr in die berge gehen wir jetzt
auch mit elvira kiss genauer in die
weinberge
denn am thema wein kommt man hier nun
wirklich nicht vorbei
[Musik]
egal wo sie hingehen überall begegnen
sie waren nicht nur diesem ganzen mehr
von reden sondern auch überall im ort
die ganze gastronomie die ganzen
unterkünfte sind eigentlich alles auf
ein paar ausgerichtet elvira kiss ist
nicht nur winzerin sie ist auch im
tourismus verein aktiv dieses jahr kamen
corona bedingt bis sehr viel weniger
besucher als sonst
das frühlings geschäft komplett ins
wasser gefallen ist seit mitte mai läuft
langsam wieder an
[Musik]
die erleichterung die ist das können sie
deutlich spüren sie sehen schon an den
leuten sie bewegen sich ganz anders sie
gehen ganz anders wieder auf die gäste
zu da kann sie kaiserstuhl ist ja sehr
sehr gastfreundlich wir sind ein
gastliches land sowohl zum wohnen als
auch zum essen und zum trinken und das
sind alle konnten nur auf ordnung jetzt
ist es wieder soweit jetzt dürfen wir
wieder gäste empfangen
man muss natürlich die vorschriften
erfüllen hier die maske abstand halten
draußen geht das mit dem abstand halten
natürlich am besten gut dass das wetter
hier sehr oft mitspielt reinhold treiber
zeigt mir diese felsen vulkanisches
gestein
tatsächlich stand hier vor 18 millionen
jahren ein riesiger vulkan
früher waren hier 600 meter mehr steine
über uns der vulkanes plus abgetragen
weil das alles das heißt wir wollen wir
denn jetzt mittendrin quasi in der lava
oder ja wir werden mittendrin also das
wäre das heiße herzen zu sagen hier wird
es brodeln hier würde die magma nach
oben schießen und es sind im erkalteten
herz des vulkans vulkangestein plus
lössboden plus warme temperaturen sorgen
hier für eine tier und pflanzenwelt die
sonst so nur selten gibt
und auch das ist etwas ungewöhnliches
eine wärmequelle mit wasser das nach
ziemlich langer zeit wieder nach oben
drückt das wasser hat was besonderes
geboten nicht sondern es ist tatsächlich
sehr alt es ist drei bis 10.000 jahre
alt also dieses wasser ist vor 10.000
jahren versichert in den weg und kommt
jetzt mit hohem druck raus wir fahren
noch einmal sollten die weinberge zum
kräftemessen in ein paar ortstypischen
disziplinen bei den winterspielen ist
rät hochkonzentriert an gegen jona und
manuela disziplin 1 heute weinflaschen
verkaufen und wieder entkommen
neidlos muss ich anerkennen dass die
beiden mehr routine haben als ich bei
disziplin zwei geht's mit diesen kleinen
rollern den weinberg hang runter und
anschließend im sprint wieder zurück
in der tat als jona schneller also
wieder verloren durchatmen bevor es
gleich an die letzte disziplin geht's
alois und 34 in grün hatten die idee für
die winterspiele und bieten auch viele
andere events am kaiserstuhl an
[Musik]
geocaching weinprobe zum beispiel ist
ein event von uns das heißt die leute
werden mit gps geräten ausgestattet und
im weinberg sind vier stationen
versteckt wo weine hinterlegt sind weine
mineralwasser bist du hast zu klappern
wir haben junggesellenabschiede wir
haben aber auch viele ältere die schon
in rente sind und so die bei uns touren
machen die dann eher für informationen
zu haben sind für die kulinarik für den
guten wein natürlich apropos wein für
uns steht jetzt die letzte disziplin der
winterspiele an weinsorten erkennen ich
war dann zwischen weißer und grauer
burgund aber ich dachte dann her grauer
burgunder immerhin zwei von drei
herausgefunden mit ein bisschen glück am
ende gewinnt manuela aber auch diese
disziplin für ihr team
er sagt trotzdem sehr viel spaß bereitet
nicht nur die winzer spiele sondern der
ganze kaiserstuhl
[Musik]